let's talk about um some of these other
talking points we have in the in the
description here uh number two we've got
is the truth about peptides um
you've got to be above average intellect
to use them what do you mean by that
okay so this is i'm glad you brought
that up because i was going to get into
this so as you know which will be
talking about the course we launched the
course in early april
uh did you know the typical one week
launch and now you know people like
yourself are promoting it you know ben
greenfield promoted it
and what we found richard
this is crazy
is that
you cannot be and again this is not you
know probably not probably nobody in
your crowd to be honest with you but an
average person
you know of an average iq
attempts to use peptides and they're
going to get confused
and the reason that is as you know is
uh
reconstitution of you know two milligram
five milligram 10 milligram vials you
know understanding the difference
between a microgram and a milligram uh
you know understanding the difference
between bacterial static water and the
and the constituent of the raw peptide
there's a lot of little sciency things
you know that are involved in the usage
of these things that the average person
is like dude
i mean i mean like i'll give you a
better example give me a pill is what
they're saying right
that's why they go to their doctor and
get a pharmaceutical i'll give you a
better example people will listen to our
stuff this will happen to you it's
probably already happened to you 100
times for all i know and they're like oh
my god you got me so excited i want to
heal you know i went and bought it you
know i ordered the syringes blah blah
and then it's like
oh [ __ ]
what you know what do i do now yeah what
did i do like well did you listen
so you know this is coming from nick and
i you know we did a private uh group
call about three weeks about this we're
kind of like there's a certain level of
intellect
that you really have to possess you know
from a critical thinking and discernment
standpoint that like no amount of videos
of me or you
pinching and withdrawing and injecting
and all that stuff is really going to
teach you unless you have this like like
i said it's like this minimum standard
of information and knowledge and and so
that's where it really gets weird is
like do your homework if you're going to
listen to this today and you're going to
buy these and obviously both of us
recommend that you do go down this path
for so many reasons just pay attention
and and richard you know to to people in
the public's defense there's not a lot
of great information out there
there's bro boards you know
peptide research chemical company
websites with information but there's
not a lot of really good information in
there and i've told you this before i
think on one of our podcasts and maybe
it was in private but when nick and i
and i'm talking about nick andrews uh
who's the co-founder of my company is
cyr
and you know nick uh you know when we
when we went to
a4m in 2018 together in las vegas the
big anti-aging convention you know we
were at the two biggest peptide vendor
booths
and we saw all the doctors rushing up
there and we were listening to their
questions and were like oh my god you
know these people are writing scripts
for these things and they don't even
know the first thing
you know so that's kind of where we are
and you know so even doctors you know as
you know this the majority of people
that have purchased the course are
doctors and some of the questions i feel
from them are like you're [ __ ]
writing scripts to patients
right so there is like this basic level
of awareness and knowledge that somebody
has to have and obviously if you take
our course which we'll talk about you
know not to be a shill you know you can
gain that but it is difficult it's it's
not you know buy it over line comes to
your house and then boom you start
injecting it it's not that simple
it's
i would say it's a little bit
overwhelming at first but once you get
your head wrapped around the basics of
reconstituting a dry powder in a vial
yeah how to draw it into like a backfill
syringe how to backfill an insulin
syringe where to inject you know like
how often do you inject uh there's
i mean you can't get around it right
like there's not much in the way of
peptides that
that will be useful if it passes through
your digestive tract it has to generally
go into like it it has to go into your
skin there's there's really no way
around it if you want the healing
benefits you're going to have to poke a
tiny little hole in your body um so
richard let's talk about that because do
you have so first off yes and thank you
for saying it but do you have any idea
how many doctors
are out there
and again not their fault that they're
as clueless but they are buying oral i
just this is again new stuff that we
find out from the people who are
purchasing course they're buying oral
lozenges
of these injectable peptides these
compound pharmacies are preying on these
the ignorance
of these doctors i mean i had a really
smart guy who follows me messaged me
about a month ago maybe five weeks ago
he bought the course and he's like look
man i bought the course because i love
you i support your work but he goes i've
been using peptides for three years and
they don't work for me and i'm like what
are you talking about and then he tells
me that he's been taking a lozenge of it
for moreland
i'm i'm like what
who who told you he sends me pictures
and i'm like jesus christ so then it's
like you realize that again it's buyer
beware
pray or be prayed upon
you know all these people out there in
the medical community who are clueless
are now being taken advantage of people
that are supposed to be their allies
selling them worthless oral lozenges so
let's go back to what you just said this
is very important for anybody watching
this podcast
you cannot take a peptide
okay now there are rare exceptions
and there are people out there like you
know seeds and some of these other
people that are selling bpc in a capsule
and bpc in a capsule is essentially
worthless i know i'm going to get mad
people are going to get mad at me
because the dosage you already said at
richard that is required to be orally
bioactive is not found in the capsules
that you're buying them now i'm not
going to tell you that you won't get
some benefit for your microbiome because
again in the stomach you'll get
something but if you expect to take an
oral capsule of bpc with a delt injury a
joint of the elbow a knee an ankle
you're fooling yourself you're not going
to get jack [ __ ] you even if you took
the whole bottle
it's not about the actual dosage in the
capsule it's about as you said richard
it's about first passed through the
digestive tract the only way an oral
capsule of medication is effective is
through an alkylation process a methyl
alkylation process which means it has to
pass through the liver which as you know
richard with anabolic steroids that are
oral you know that's what causes liver
damage and really anything that's methyl
alkylated if taken repeatedly will cause
damage to your hepatic system which is
the liver function
so all these people out there that are
buying bpc and dude you know this
there's facebook companies now you see
them they're in your ads
buy this bpc i've seen wolverine healing
and all this nonsense and then i look at
the dosage and i'm like anybody who buys
that is getting ripped off
because there's not enough active
ingredient and even if there was and by
the way it's illegal if they put an
active amount
it doesn't make it through the digestive
system so you have to inject now
before somebody fax checks me and leaves
me something on here there are some
intranasal peptides there are definitely
some
cognitive nootropic enhancing peptides
that you can snort
but as i always say who the [ __ ] wants
to snort
a neutrophil can you can inject it and
then again you know again to fact check
myself there are some oral nootropic
peptides like dihexa
uh c-max and celank that you can take
that are affected but outside of that
richard as you said everything
has to be injected highest impact most
bioavailable in the body into portal
circulation you have to inject it if
you're buying peptides and orally
sucking them
or licking them or lozenging them you're
not you're getting ripped off hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you